that's a treat to talk to you
rob mighty obsessed with karate kid 3.
so i feel like this all coming together
is a little bit of a dream come true
first i know you took some time to
explore writing and producing more over
the years so did you find that
experience behind the scenes influencing
your work as an actor on set when you
started working on cobra kai uh season
four
immensely so um because i've been a
full-time writer for so long now and it
you know
there's such a crossover in the arts and
when you're when you're writing you know
you especially when it comes down to the
dialogue site you're really living up
and playing each character so there's
always that part of me that i said you
know um was still alive and when this
came along to walk on set and take all
that experience from behind the scenes
and watching it happen to say now you're
that person and just being able to focus
on one entity and be able to live and
breathe through that it was very freeing
you know it was a very um fulfilling
experience for me
all right jumping into terry silver
specifics now i'm wondering what kind of
story details did you have to fill in in
between the events of karate kid 3 and
cobra kai season 4 to you know figure
out why terry is where he is at the
beginning of the show and also what
influences him when he makes certain
decisions throughout it well that was a
big part of of taking the job because
that's the question i had for the
creators um john josh and hayden when
you know i first zoomed with them um and
they had mapped out this whole backstory
going back to the whole vietnam story
the whole relationship with chris the
whole loyalty and um and then
bring you know what has that guy been
doing for the last 30 years to bring
this guy who has been who has so
educated himself and become you know an
artist in his own way and you you have
to think to be able to do this you know
the things musically does or the art he
has on the wall that
is a tremendous amount of devotion of
time and energy and discipline so i see
where he brought you know his his
martial arts to this world but still
throughout that i just felt there was
always these buried inner demons that
you know he was trying to always keep at
it keep it a
at arm's arms reach and then when he's
brought back into this world it sort of
like begins to unravel for him which was
a great beautiful gray area to live in
all right i have to put the spoiler
warning up for these last two questions
so you could talk about these details
freely but
i i wrestle with this question from
season to season with crease and now i'm
kind of wondering the same thing with
terry
do you think that there is a path to
redemption for him or
is the extreme version of him we see at
the end of the season
truly who he is deep down and there's
just no coming back from that
that's a great big question and you go
um
i think that's a question terry asked
you know and
he here's the it's like
if terry
what he tried to put out asking for
forgiveness
came back if what he tried to put out to
say i believe in what i'm doing in our
society right now today i can impact
kids
positively and give them something a
tool that they need we may not believe
in that you may not believe in it i mean
but terry believes in that and if i can
give them that then i'm doing something
good and that's very important for terry
to believe that he does throughout the
whole thing now
was you know is he right in that now
does he it's it he does go to an extreme
but i think that's because of the
background he's had and the lack of you
know love for uh a simplistic way of
looking at it that how he expresses that
um but you always hope that there's
there's you know
he's redeemable in some way you wanna
you know you just and i think he
believes in his heart
you have to believe that you know it not
only to be redeemable but you're going
to be redeemed because you were doing
something you were going against all
odds everyone said this is wrong but you
believed in it you committed to it
cobra kai is a show that has given me
faith that the way that the writers
tackle it it still leaves hope for
everybody no matter what they do no
matter what they believe and they've
they've proven me wrong with my
redemption doubts all along and i think
that they could do it again perry that's
why i love these guys because literally
anything is possible and whenever you
predict and think oh you expect
something they're going to twist it up
you know and it's it's wonderful and
after to be going through that this is
why it's one of my favorite shows up and
running right now huge congratulations
i'm so happy to have you back in this
world
thank you thank you thanks for your time
my pleasure thank you
you